اتخذت الحرب في اوكرانيا منحا جديدا
وخطيرا بعد تفجير سد نوفا كاخوفكا لما
يمثله هذا السد من اهميه استراتيجيه كبرى
سد نوفا كخوفكا سيطرت عليه روسيا في بدايه
الحرب ويقع السد على نهر نيبرو على بعد 30
كم شرقي مدينه خرسون في جنوب اوكرانيا كما
نشاهد هنا ويقطن مشاهدينا هذه المنطقه
اكثر من 16 الف شخص يحتوي خزان السد على
ما يقدر بنحو 18 كيلومترا مكعبا من المياه
ويبلغ ارتفاع هذا السد 30 مترا وعرضه طبعا
مئات الامتار تفجير هذا السد الضخم يعادل
تاثيره تاثير انفجار قنبله نوويه وسيؤدي
طبعا الى عواقب بيئيه واقتصاديه
وتكنولوجيه ضخمه جدا وفقا هنا طبعا
لمسؤولين روس واوكرانيين تحدثوا بعد تفجير
هذا السد وخلال اربعه ايام
المياه المنطقه برماتها لاجل ذلك يجب
اجراء المدنيين والحيوانات باسرع وقت ممكن
لتجنب الكارثه لاسيما بعد تدمير اربعه
توربينات في منطقه ومحطه
نوفاكا جنوبي اوكرانيا الذي سيزيد من
ارتفاع منسوبه المياه طبعا الى عشره امتار
هذه الكارثه ستخلف عواقب وخيمه وخطيره على
البشر حيث هناك نقص مياه في خزان نوفا
سيؤدي طبعا مشاهدينا الى جفاف الحقول في
جنوب اوكرانيا وهو ما تحدث عنه كل
المسؤولين كما ان عشرات المصانع الكبرى
ستتوقف نهائيا عن العمل بسبب قله المياه
وانقطاع الكهرباء مما سيؤدي طبعا الى
عواقب بالغه في هذه المنطقه في المرحله
المقبله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات